all right here's the first story from
the daily mail armed man who attacked
fbi's ohio field office is dead after
five hour standoff suspect also attended
deadly capital riot now
we don't know exactly to what extent he
was at the capitol riot i think that
maybe the daily mail's reporting
something different i've read a bunch of
other sources the new york times says
that he was there the night before but
he's not been charged with any crimes
but let's uh let's read and see what
they say
ricky walter schiffer was shot dead by
police thursday
after he raised a gun towards officers
around 3 p.m
state highway patrol confirmed schifrin
attempted to break into the office
prompting a five-hour standoff with
authorities the body armor wearing
suspect fled the office and was chased
onto highway onto the highway man
copyrighted guys before abandoning his
car by a cornfield on a country road
just off of interstate 71 the
confrontation came as officials warned
of an increase in threats against
federal agents in the days following the
search a search of former president
donald trump's mar-a-lago estate in
florida investigators say schiffer was
also at the u.s capitol during the
january 6 insurrection they report
all right well they reported this stuff
i'm going to pull up some tweets that we
have
travis view says the new york times
identified the ohio shooting suspect as
ricky schiffer there is a truth social
account using that name on the same day
the fbi executed a warrant on mar-a-lago
the account made a call to be ready for
combat and i'm not going to read what he
said next but he called for extreme
violence wow
in the end
one of the last things he said
was that um yeah i can't i don't wanna i
don't think we should read exactly what
he said but he explained that he thought
he had a way to get through bulletproof
glass he was wrong he did not but this
could explain why it was reported that
he fired a nail gun at the at the fbi
now i read on nbc he fired at the agents
but perhaps they said towards them
instead of add was because there was
bulletproof glass he was not able to
penetrate but apparently this ricky
shifter guy on truth social was saying
that he did it and if you don't hear
from it's because they got him or
something to that effect so um
i guess
my view on things obviously
george conway all right i'm gonna make
sure i cite george conway on this one
he said they crossed the rubicon
this is anti-trumper george conway they
crossed the rubicon which is an
insinuation that
a faction of people have crossed the
point of no return
towards what a civil war yeah but
oh uh there's nothing there's some
random dude that went crazy in my
opinion no no no no no no no he's he's
talking about the democrats in the fbi
right
specifically so uh ian you you've you've
talked quite a bit about you know
ancient roman stuff like that the um
crossing of the rubicon yeah it was
forbidden in rome there's a river right
outside the city and if i get any of
this wrong just correct me in the chat
and i'd be happy to go over it again but
that it was illegal to ever bring troops
across the river into the city of rome
that was something they'd all decided it
was too dangerous so when caesar was off
on campaign he had you know however many
hundreds thousands of troops that just
basically worshipped him and when he
decided he came back to rome he's like
they were going to try and put him on
trial to strip him of his power and he
was like you know what no i want rome he
crossed the rubicon with his troops took
the city and they called it forever
known as the crossing of the rubicon is
when you've taken that step the one step
too far and that was the
that was the start of the civil war that
was basically the end of the roman
republic in the beginning of the empire
so
there was a leftist outlet that they
were like the far right is saying this
that or otherwise or something like that
and uh they said tim poole said they
crossed the rubicon and i'm like yeah
and so did george conway like this is
not a call to anything it's a statement
of it's an observation
i think they did yeah and uh first and
foremost obviously let me just say one
thing
this dude who went to the fbi field
office must have really wanted democrats
to win
because the i mean we're months out from
the midterm election and
surprisingly he did exactly what the
democrats needed
he got violent failed and now the
democrats have their example of what's
wrong with the right that's why
the craziest thing to me is like now is
the absolute worst time for anything
like that and this is why i say violence
doesn't work we are we are months away
from republicans taking the house and
the senate in what the misery index
predicts will be a crushing defeat
except now in the past few months
democrats have even doubted the polling
something like this happens i think
we're going to see democrats spiking in
the polls because of this yeah no i
agree i mean
this is this is the continuance of the
january 6th hysteria this is how they
continue that that line of conversation
but i i think that
we need to be a little bit careful and
you know knowing that this was the guy
because
i was trying to google which mass
shooting was it where it was the brother
that was identified and it went on for
hours and this guy like he was getting
calls do you remember was it newtown
i don't remember which shooting it was
but there was a there was a mass
shooting where the brother was falsely
identified um and so i would just you
know
caution the expertise of whoever this
guy is with q and ron
like maybe it's not him and maybe this
guy well the new york times said this oh
well that's that's the right yeah that's
the beacon of truth and reality i mean
sure but i i guess the best thing we can
do is i mean i always just wait 24 hours
right fair point fair point and even if
even if it turns out that this is the
guy i i don't think blaming a political
party or a movement or any of that makes
any sense because this guy just went off
the rails yeah i mean it's it's the same
as the baseball shooter
the what's that debate the congressional
baseball shooter that was never blamed
on democrats
um yeah it's a guy who uh i think he was
like even maybe a bernie sanders
supporter he was he was he was a
brainstorm
scalise and like he opened fire at the
the congressional baseball
practice
and almost killed steve scalise i mean
very few people know about it because it
was a story for like 0.3 days meanwhile
january 6th we've been talking about
forever
but
i mean that was never that violence that
was never crossing the rubicon that was
never blamed on democrats it was just
like whoa it's just some crazy guy like
why this is just something this guy this
crazy guy right now i don't think is
crossing the is is a crossing of the
rubicon i think the weaponization of the
doj and garland being like yeah i signed
off on this is a crossing of the rubicon
yes and going into melania's closet yeah
i mean look we've talked about this when
trump was saying he would lock up
hillary everybody was like that would be
a dangerous time in this country and
then what did trump do he said we're not
going to go after early we're not going
to do it and everybody was disappointed
but trump was like no no you know we're
not going to do it and they didn't yeah
trump was standing at that river line he
was like no no that's too much it's too
much and public yep meanwhile hillary
has her happy
her but her emails hats she's
campaigning already or at least
fundraising go ahead dude i think i
watched merrick garland he did a speech
today the official like explanation they
said they're going to unseal the warrant
to explain why they
invaded is that the right word trump's
house i don't know what the word is here
rated rated they said but don't call it
a raid it was a radio yeah i mean they
went in there you know unannounced um or
maybe they announced themselves right
before they went in well they did they
went to the lawyer they said get out
we're gonna go do our thing apparently
they kept the uh
the cameras rolling so rubicon i don't
know jury's still out i want to see what
the warrant said
there is always the possibility that
trump was doing something extremely
nefarious and a warrant wouldn't prove
that
okay but would not you know a warrant is
their accusation yeah of pro or maybe
they have their wife
him and then they heard him say you know
no one we don't know i mean it's hard
not to view this as a complete fishing
expedition right they i mean why would
you write i'm sorry i'm sorry it's hard
to view this as anything other than
fake
and weaponization why
because of russiagate because of ukraine
gate because we know they had fabricated
evidence and manipulated evidence
already so you know forgive me
hillary clinton's email server we looked
at they they said well there's no
criminal intent fine
then they smear and lie about trump they
should have stopped the investigation
into russia gate long time ago yeah what
would happen a lawyer chain like
fabricated a a letter or something it's
been a while since i covered the story
but anyway sorry i digress oh all i was
gonna say is that to me this warrant you
know we've heard the story that there
was a
a room that had a padlock on it that had
the documents that are requesting when
you write a warrant you have to be
specific about what you're asking for so
theoretically garland signed off an
award that said we want complete and
unfettered access and we want the right
to not announce because we think that
they'll hide stuff
that to me indicates that it's a it's a
grab they want to see as get as much
stuff as possible and then maybe justify
it later when they're like oh but look
what we found when we showed up there
yeah well in melania's closet there were
all these secret things that we knew
about so uh to understand what is it
called the fruit of the poison tree is
that what it's called yeah there's the
exclusionary rule and this states that
um
if your rights are violated and evidence
is found that evidence is inadmissible
in court so there was one story i i
remember reading about back in illinois
of a guy who had they thought he was a
murderer and so a cop ran his plates
pulled him over and then while he he
said get out of the car illegally
searches the car finds evidence
send in the evidence turns out the stop
was illegal the lawyers get it thrown
out exclusionary rule you cannot use
evidence seized in violation of
someone's rights with this you get a
warrant for something like classified
documents
then once you're inside if you have a
warrant and you enter a home looking for
say classified documents and you find
pills and a gun
that's now admissible so anything they
found in the house perhaps this was a
fishing expedition and or trump's
suggesting they're planting evidence
that's a bold yeah that's the first
thing that crossed my mind when i heard
about this story what if they play like
how can you yeah confirm or deny if they
did that i mean i wouldn't put it past
them i was gonna say i think of all
there's like been over a hundred
subpoenas that have been issued through
the january six uh subcommittee when you
subpoena people's documents and records
you can ask broadly for tons and tons of
stuff they aren't being specific in what
they want and that to me
shows that they are kind of grasping at
straws like they are wanting you to turn
over stuff so they can figure out later
what you did wrong that's creepy yeah
can is that the kind of thing where they
can
create like fabricate a warrant after
the fact and make it look like they had
it back in the day no we we know this
guy this this epstein-linked judge
signed off on it thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there
you